Today I'm crafting with two of the youngest members
of our team.
It's Bring Your Child to Work Day
and I want you to meet Layla and Hailey.
(audience cheering)
Now, Layla's dad
is actually our show's phenomenal director, Adam.
That's right.
And Hailey's mom is the associate director,
the one and only Sarah.
(audience cheering)
And they are in our control room.
Now, it's been a busy year at our show
and I wanted to give their parents a little break
but mostly, I just wanted to hang out with Hailey and Layla.
Hi, girls.
Hi.
How are you today?
I'm good.
How's homeschool going?
Are you sick of it?
Yeah.
Oh gosh.
15 months.
Wow, good counting.
(Layla chuckling)
Yeah, are you ready to go back to actual school?
Yeah, I'm probably going on the 19th of April.
Again, really good numbering.
You know what I would give for my kids
to know their calendar?
They all tease me about the calendar
'cause I love my calendar.
I love my calendar.
(audience chuckling)
And how are you feeling about school, Hailey?
Good.
Yeah?
And do you feel like you're learning in virtual school?
Well, I'm in school full time
and I already know lots of stuff
that they're teaching us in school.
So you're in school
and you're one smarty pants, aren't you?
(audience cheering)
You know what?
You remind me exactly of your mother
because she is so confident
and she knows how to get her job done
and we all look to her to get it done
because confidence is a very wonderful quality in someone.
That's your mom, she's the one
who says I know what to do.
Oh, I'm so happy to be doing this with you guys.
All right, so now, we're gonna get into some crafting.
One of the places that I have gone to
with my daughters throughout our whole lives
is a very important place in New York.
It's called The Craft Studio.
And it's a female-owned New York City-based business
that provides kids with craft parties,
classes and art workshops.
I'll tell you this, my daughters
have never had a birthday party
that didn't involve The Craft Studio.
And I would like to meet our instructor.
She happens to be someone I know and love.
It's The Craft Studio's Lindsey Peers.
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much for having me.
I'm so excited to be here.
What are we making today?
I love it, so we are making
these beautiful tissue paper flowers you guys all have
in front of your desk.
Look how fun.
Okay, first, for parents and kids at home,
we have a quick clip to show you how to get started.
(upbeat music)
Oh, I love that.
Okay, does everyone have their kit in front of them?
Let's get started.
So you ready to rock, guys?
Yeah, I'm excited.
Okay, so starting on the bottom layer,
like we're holding it like a stem.
Good job, okay, perfect.
We're gonna open and bloom our flower.
We're gonna open it up so it forms like a half circle
on each side
and you're gonna slowly separate the tissue paper layers.
And it's like a flower coming to life in bloom.
So go around and around
and what I love about this project
is it's so much fun for littles
but also, it looks so beautiful and elegant
and it could be on your table
and a centerpiece of a beautiful dinner party
we all hope to have soon.
Oh, I love a table scaping idea.
Right, isn't that cool?
Do your parents ever ask you to help set the table?
Yeah.
Sometimes.
I love your reaction, Hailey.
You're lik mhmm.
I know.
Maybe from now on
they can help you to ask do the table flowers.
Oh yeah, and you can make 'em
for any season, which is so fun.
That's right, you could do like red, green
and white for Christmas.
You could do autumnal colors for Thanksgiving.
Yes, you can make a little 4th of July one.
Warm and cold colors.
That's right, and 4th of July,
the possibilities are endless.
Endless possibilities.
And you saw on the piece how we frayed the different edges,
you can get funky with that
when you're putting your tissue paper together.
I love it.
That's so fun.
Oh, beautiful, look at that.
You can accessorize.
Oh my goodness, Layla, it's fantastic.
Hailey, let's see yours.
Oh, my God, you guys have done
such an amazing job.
Layla, I think yours really reminds me
of a lily pond that has these beautiful poky petals
in the center.
And then yours looks sort of very wide and sunflower-y.
It's floating on the river.
Yeah, exactly, floating on a river.
Exactly.
Hailey and Layla, I am so happy that we got
to do crafts with you today.
Let's please do this again.
Yes.
Well, I know where to find your parents.
And Lindsey, thank you so much.
You've been such a good friend
over the years and I just love the fact
that The Craft Studio is in our small business guide
and we promote it.
The Craft Studio's here in New York
and it really is a great place for families to go.
Thank you for being a champion for all small businesses
and I love creating magic with you.
You bring so much magic everywhere.
Thank you, Drew.
Thank you, Lindsey.
Don't be surprised if this is strapped
to my next outfit.
(upbeat music)